الحرب هو هذا الشتاء لن تكون كما كانت
روسيا رغم خسارتها لاراضي اقليم خاركيز
الا انها تمكنت حتى الان من سد الهجوم
الاوكرانيه على دومباز وخرسون حرب الشتاء
مختلفه والسؤال مع من سيتحالف الشتاء هذه
المره
روسيا بدات الخطه مبكرا استهدفت منشات
البقاء الضروريه في اوكرانيا المدن
الاوكرانيه الكبرى بدون ماء وبقاء سكان
بدون تدفئه بحلول الشتاء مستحيل
ولقتنا روسيه اخرى اللاجئون سيتفقون على
اوروبا بالملايين وموسكو بذلك سوف تضرب
عصفورين بحجر واحد اغرقوا اوروبا
بالمهاجرين وافراغ المدن الاوكرانيه من
سكانها مما سيسهل اقتحامها لاحقا
اما بالنسبه لارض الميدان اكتساؤل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بالحله البيضاء سيجعل المعدات
العسكريه مكشوفه الثلوج تستخدم في هذه
الحالات لزرع الالغم واخفائها وهذا عدا عن
الاسلحه التي تفقد الكثير من فعاليتها
نتيجه البرد موسم الوحلات سيكون اخطر من
اشهر الجليد ربما وطول الامطار الغزيره
سيعيق الرؤيه انظمه الملاحه وحتى صور
الاقمار الصناعيه ستفقد الكثيره ستفقد
الكثيره من ثقتها اللون الابيض لان يفرش
البساط الاحمر لاين من الطرفين في البقاء
على الاراضي الاخرانيه سيكون مرهقا
للرؤوس خمس مئه مليون دولار على الاقل
يوميا بحسب اليوزميك خاصه انك تحضر تحضر
لحرب الاستنزاف تعتمد على المدفعيه بعيده
المدى
ايامه صعبه تعيشها هذه الايام اوكرانيا في
ظل انقطاعات الطاقه الكهربائيه حيث تاثرت
اربع محطات رئيسيه باستهدافات روسيه واخرى
توقفت بشكل ملحوظ يتوقع ان يتضرر من موسم
شتاء هذا العام داخل اوكرانيا اكثر من 4
ملايين ونصف مليون شخص اذا استمرت
انقطاعات الطاقه ومحطات التدفئه